in this film everyone is a suspect
everyone there's a lot of that in the
film in terms of actors of either you
know looking at each other suspiciously
or not looking guilty or you know
there's not so because that happens a
lot were the ways that you rang the
changes did you or did you just kind of
go do it again well I heard about what I
heard about ways I heard about ways
brought over from the Americans whatever
from the Americas my character actually
liked to expound there's Shakespeare
there's a theater and then and then just
as watch well there's there's the who
farted look on the train there was this
scene where we're all look Ken's
direction does is everybody look
suspiciously at everybody else and
everybody's like like that Judi and I
looked at Leslie and Daisy and I go all
we really have to do is wonder who just
farted job so much easier and that's
literally what you see on screen
okay let's practice let's practice
you're suspicious poker faces so you're
suspicious but you didn't do it okay so
we'll just imagine someone on the sofa
has just let one rip okay oh maybe
you're terrible ken do you but someone
has let one
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay come on focus everyone okay here we
go here we go so somebody somebody has
let one drop is it Josh he looks like a
farter this is Canada big lunch
Michelle has never fought
[Laughter]
Julie smelling it really strong
[Applause]
Donnelly's check making a blood house or
is it the host
[Music]
[Applause]